hey folks welcome back to scp explained
sorry if i seem a little out of it today
truth be told i've been having real
trouble sleeping lately perhaps it's
because i spend so much time pouring
through the files of the scp foundation
archive also i've been catching up on
the west wing there's plenty of
creatures entities objects and tales
that are very effective at making you
lose sleep but none quite as effective
as
scp-966 grab yourself a pot of coffee
and prop your eyelids open with some
matchsticks or tape because you need to
stay alert if you want to survive this
one though when you get on the wrong
side of scp-966
i'm sorry to tell you that your chances
of survival are extremely low and after
experiencing its primary anomalous
effects the question of how long you'll
even want to survive will become
disturbingly prescient like many of our
explorations into the living nightmares
that the scp foundation deals with on a
daily basis the best way to experience
exactly what
scp-966 can do is to take a look at a
case study regarding one of its many
unfortunate victims in this case that
victim is a man named terry hallberg
from new mexico in another life perhaps
terry would have been an ideal candidate
for a junior researcher position at the
scp foundation he was a
scientific-minded truth-seeker whose
interests lied in the more esoteric
fields of study namely ghosts and aliens
proving the existence of life in the
stars and the supernatural in general
was something he considered to be his
life's work this is why he moved to new
mexico home of roswell and widely
considered to be the ufo capital of the
united states in the first place there
he'd perform experiments on a wide range
of bizarre phenomenon from exploring
haunted houses to obsessively watching
the sky for any anomalous activity he'd
become a big wig in his niche online
paranormal investigation community and
his posts on the somewhat infamous
periwatch forum always garnered plenty
of attention but terry wanted more he
wasn't in it for the fame or the money
or the legions of insatiable paranormal
investigator groupies he was a true
believer he wanted a close first-hand
experience with the supernatural and
that was exactly what he was about to
get in addition to a very harsh lesson
about being careful what you wish for it
began when he got called out to
albuquerque for a strange case of cattle
mutilation for those who don't frequent
the parawatch forums quite as often as
terry cattle mutilation is the most
common nickname for the phenomenon of
large livestock usually cows being found
dead with unusual mutilation patterns on
their corpses while the particulars of
what exactly this means varies from
believer to believer with theories
ranging from aliens to black helicopters
it is widely accepted across all
branches of paranormal enthusiasts that
when cattle are being mutilated
something very strange is afoot terry
arrived at the ranch and with the
application of a little cache to grease
the appropriate palms he was able to
conduct a recorded interview with the
rancher he was a weathered man in his
early 60s with a somewhat frantic
demeanor and profoundly tired eyes when
terry asked him if he'd experienced any
unusual phenomenon in the days leading
up to the cattle mutilation incident he
was surprisingly forthcoming about the
hellish conditions he'd been
experiencing lately the strange
experiences had been going on for
several days now it all started when the
rancher noticed that a number of his
cows weren't sleeping this isn't the
easiest thing to spot in a cow because
cattle engage in what is known as
polyphasic sleep where instead of
sleeping for one prolonged period like
humans typically do they sleep in small
intervals throughout a 24 hour period
cows can even sleep standing up for
periods of light rest but during rem
sleep which all mammals need for healthy
functioning they lay down just like us
the problem was in the last several days
many of the ranchers cows hadn't slept
at all it was after this that the
ranchers seemingly begin to have bizarre
paranormal experiences himself it began
with a general sense of unease and dread
which was soon followed by a sense of
severe insomnia that had left him
completely unable to sleep for the past
two days during this period things had
gotten worse he'd experienced strange
noises around his home footsteps what
sounded like hushed voices and
occasionally even what could only be
identified as a low croaking growl but
it wasn't just noises there was also
physical evidence of some kind of
intrusion
items had been knocked over or moved at
one point a glass of water which had
been centralized on a stable surface had
somehow fallen off the edge and
shattered the old rancher with a
trembling voice even stated that he'd
seen things moving in the corners of his
eyes figures
shapes little green men and then the
cattle mutilation spree began it may
have sounded morbid but terry had to use
everything in his power to stop himself
from smiling ear to ear well this was a
terrifying experience for the rancher
for terry this was an absolutely
textbook case of paranormal experience
and here he was the very first person to
document it all it could be the next
skinwalker ranch or rental shum forest
incident and his name would forever be
attached to it he asked the rancher if
he could see the cow's body and the
rancher obliged whatever had caused this
alien ghost or otherwise had really done
a number on this cow good portions of
its abdomen had been torn away with
evidence of what appeared to be biting
and clawing this poor beast had been
eaten alive while exploring the wounds
with a magnifying glass a scalpel and a
large pair of tweezers terry discovered
something incredible something frankly
unprecedented for a cattle mutilation
case a piece of evidence left behind
directly by whatever had perpetrated
this act of gruesome violence a long
thin and exceedingly sharp claw around
12 centimeters in length and broken at
one end new mexico's large predators
included mountain lions black bears
bobcats and coyotes and this claw was
nothing like any of those in fact it was
nothing like terry had ever seen before
was this his big moment had he
discovered evidence of an entirely new
supernatural creature or specimen of
extraterrestrial life he was practically
vibrating with excitement about this new
discovery after thanking and paying the
rancher again terry took some photos
gathered some more samples and laughed
he had everything he needed to conduct a
groundbreaking investigation into the
supernatural just wait until the folks
on parawatch heard about this in all his
excitement as he drove back home from
the ranch he never once stopped to
consider what he might be bringing back
with him but really in the end it didn't
even matter from the moment he stepped
onto that ranch terry hallberg was
already doomed he just didn't know it
yet he arrived home and began to record
all of his information onto one master
document he also began obsessively
assembling outside research hoping to
find similar cases that he could add to
this emerging pattern it was a mix of
phenomenon from both hauntings and alien
encounters could this possibly be some
form of alien ghost the dream find of
every paranormal investigator terry had
to steal his racing heart as the
possibilities bombarded his mind he
could have been working with the
paranormal find of the century here in
fact he was so excited by all of this he
didn't even realize that he worked
through the entire night he didn't sleep
a wink after all how could you when such
important research needed to be done the
burst of nocturnal energy felt like a
godsend the next night not so much in
the meantime terry had compiled his
information together enough to present
it to his esteemed paranormal colleagues
on the periwatch forums they were
startled and amazed by what they were
seeing and hearing especially the taped
interview with the rancher and the
mysterious claw one of terry's closest
associates who went by the username john
station pulled up a similar bizarre case
of a los angeles hiker who died in the
hills in the days before his death his
family and friends reported him
complaining about insomnia and
experiencing an increasing state of
paranoia and distress he started taking
long walks across remote trails in hopes
of tiring himself out enough to finally
get some sleep but that time never came
when his corpse was found it was mauled
and half eaten everyone assumed that a
mountain lion had killed him and other
scavengers had fed on him before his
body was found but now terry wasn't so
sure the more they looked into it the
more they found strange and unpleasant
deaths connected to people suffering
from what seemed like severe insomnia
despite its debilitating effects the
only type of insomnia that directly
causes death is the exceedingly rare
genetic condition fatal familial
insomnia which couldn't account for the
sheer number of deaths the parawatch
team were finding in their minds there
was only one reasonable conclusion the
deaths weren't the result of the
insomnia itself but whatever was causing
it it was only then that terry noticed
his own inability to sleep and his
previous excitement was gradually
replaced with panic at first he try to
keep it all in proportion knowing that
it's easy to invent things to fear when
you're in uncharted territory but as the
days passed and the sleep never came his
worry became unassailable terry knew
that he hadn't just discovered a new
paranormal phenomenon he was becoming
one of its victims he became
increasingly paranoid over the next few
days taking constant evp readings from
around his apartment in hopes of
detecting whatever was around him there
were strange noises frightening noises
he just knew it but little did poor
terry know there was a very good reason
he couldn't detect his tormentors while
he had been in his apartment for days
now he had no hope of ever seeing them
the humanized spectrum of visible light
is around 380 to 750 nanometers but the
monsters who deprived him of his ability
to sleep existed somewhere around 900
they were entirely undetectable to the
human eye and they were waiting for
their latest meal as the insomnia grew
worse terry received some frightening
news that rancher who he'd spoken to a
few days before was found dead on his
property with severe injuries comparable
to that of a wild animal attack just
like his cattle and just like all the
other strange cases the parawatch forum
had found first the insomnia then the
frightening paranormal experiences and
then
terry found something warm and wet
trickling down the back of his neck he
probably would have realized it was his
own blood if a 20 centimeter claw just
like the one he had pulled out of the
dead cow hadn't just pierced his brain
stem terry hallberg had finally gotten
what he wanted a first-hand experience
with the supernatural and all he had to
do
was die but in his defense being saved
from
scp-966 a whole species of monsters
known as the sleep killers is almost
worse than being killed by them when
they release their deadly energy pulse
their primary anomalous effect which
induces sleeplessness on anyone or
anything in their immediate 20 meter
radius the effects are permanent they
essentially induce fatal insomnia and
your only options are to die by their
claws or live long enough to see your
own body and mind give out from the
horrible effects of true sleep
deprivation they travel in pairs and
because of their invisibility you never
know when they're lurking around you
waiting to rob you of your sleep and
then your life the foundation currently
has four specimens in containment but
believe us there are a lot more out
there and they're hungry sleep tight if
you can now go check out killer living
graffiti scp-1155 predatory street art
and waldo finds you
scp-4885 find him for more terrifying
monsters that'll hunt you to your last
breath